hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
make sure you subscribe so you get the
videos as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is are you garbage
goddammit
to show we sit down with your favorite
comedians we found out they grew up
classy
or if they're a big old piece of trash
i'm your host dave trolley coming at you
on a beautiful day
i'm down here aunt tooty's basement it
feels good to be home
i think i smell chili and newports and i
like it
i'm feeling it right sorry go no please
there's the new potpourri she got i
heard ah
very nice timing my untimely co-host is
coming at you
from right next to me he is the ceo of
are you garbage he's my boss so what am
i going to do i got to laugh how's it
going
give it up for kevin james ryan
everybody hey what's up gang uh thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you rate review subscribe on itunes
still in the top 200
uh review will help us out uh
youtube.com
uh videos i'm sorry oh man
hold on we got to change the batteries
in the kitchen stop the show
youtube.com those numbers are true to
[ __ ] roof and then patreon.com
let us what our beaks baby you can go
there you can sign up you get a lot of
bonus content
there's video we played are you garbage
with our [ __ ] moms the first episode
you can get the uh the cribs edition of
foley's household
foley's childhood house it's a [ __ ]
good time sign up live streams the whole
nine yards
patreon.com are you garbage yes sir did
you mention the hard feelings
and hard feelings you get which is me
and foley chopping it up a little bit
behind the scenes me calling him fat him
calling me bald it's a good time
big hit of the season everybody loves it
get in on it and having a nice shout out
to our producer extraordinaire
the pride of the chicago comedy scene
and we're talking about old town not the
bums up in rosemont
give it up for toby mcmullen everybody
t-bone
people got no mic i forgot we love you
buddy
he's quiet but deadly over there silent
assassin listen
gang this is a family episode where we
are going to answer your questions from
patreon and with
a family episode always involves a
little company a little bit of
confidence a little family
all right it's kids from whitterson's
jump street yeah one of our first guests
on the podcast
he's a worker all right not like the
usual bozos we're getting here
we got a little star power very funny
standard comedian
among his podcasts he has j train he has
the ul podcast
but he has a brand new special that's
out right now
called socially distance of course and
it's all about the social anxiety of
2020
he filmed it in indianapolis on new
year's eve it's on his youtube page
right now
he's a good-looking cool kid yeah he's
been down in boca for a couple of months
he's got the tan
he's the kind of guy that if you were a
freshman or a sophomore
when he was a senior and he was driving
home from school and he's like yo you
guys want a ride home
you would tell your boys about it the
next day you'd be like yo fred gave us a
ride home last night
and let me tell you something don't come
slip him with a shitty cheeseboard in
front of this kid
because he's all class give it the [ __ ]
up for the j train jared freed everybody
wow what a what an introduction look at
that i believe i'm so happy for you guys
i know i'm glowing right now i've been
in boca i have that
florida mentality you turned into paul
rubinstein
literally my whole life is my whole
perspective on [ __ ] is totally different
now like i could tell the minute i got
off the flight i'm like look at these
animals
i'm like look at this weather it's
horrible and it's like
in and people bashed on florida for all
those months and i'm
sitting down there i'm on a beach i'm
hanging out baby living it taping
podcasts doing
doing as best as you can and i'm like
yeah yeah and it's like
it's good to be back here i just want to
talk to you guys about the show a year
in
a year it feels like yesterday that we
taped the episode
and i said to you i said this is gonna
be i want to make sure i'm on route this
is the boca and him talking about i
don't know
bring him over every time i turn over
he's got more jewelry on it
chest hair just keeps growing he's got a
stone crab in his hand
yeah go look at the car
i said it i hope people can go back and
listen i hope it's
is it on the episode it should be i
think it is i said this
will be a successful podcast i said it
thank you
because here's what you guys did you had
a show
you had a beginning middle and end in
mind you had a premise your premise
is all set up then you just come up and
you just knock them out and i'm proud of
you guys because now you've got a
business
that i mean the studio
sounds like i'm in roth no but i am so
impressed i'm so proud
because i i get asked a lot to do
the third episode of people's podcast
sure because people know that i have a
podcast
and they're like oh he has listeners and
well you're it's one
this is why you're a nice guy right
and you're like you're friendly you're a
nice guy you got a successful pod so
it's like oh
i remember you said you would do it of
course
we had three other people that they were
like get the [ __ ] out of here
j train's coming in you bozo's beating
and i'm gonna get your [ __ ]
get in the hallway the kid's coming in
and hi don't let him don't make eye
contact buddy we got podcast royalty
coming in
and i'm mildly successful like i'm not
even like one of those podcasts like
believe it i understand where i stand in
this
whole scheme of things i know what goes
with but when
i get asked a lot because again i have a
listenership i i i'm
uh you know you start a podcast you
gotta get jared you gotta get jared on
you gotta get like
there's a few people that get kind of
you know burdened with this yeah yeah
you know
and another person because you're nice
though you're uh you're nice you're nice
to us we know you we see you and it's
like oh
i could ask him for a face and i love
you know
again like you said chopping it up like
especially and so when i get asked to go
on the third podcast of a lot of people
is i know i'm like
they either get it or they don't a lot
of times like i think corrine fisher's
in the same position as me
sure passed on the third she was like
our eighth or something yeah
so the third episode of someone's new
podcast where they're trying to figure
it out and sometimes the person's trying
to figure out and
and they're not on they're on the wrong
road
and you see it because you're a pro and
you're like this
guys are walking the wrong direction you
guys are walking the right
direction i saw it and i said because
you're gonna
fumble you know listen uh as podcast
starts but what a lot of comics don't
a lot of comics will complain about
their standing in life
but then you ask them to put a podcast
together and they're like well i i
you know we'll do we'll just we'll just
sit here being funny what yeah
nobody cares what the [ __ ] is your show
what is the show you don't
you you're mad that you're not
successful and you couldn't even plan
a podcast that you get to put up there's
no barriers to entry
no one that has it's 99 a year to have a
podcast you couldn't yeah you couldn't
create
a [ __ ] uh program to do and it's like
and even if you couldn't you didn't have
the energy to spend an hour talking with
someone like you're
so what else you got uh when did you
start how did you start doing comedy
like
if you want to do the how'd you start
doing comedy show it's been done it's
fine i've done
the best but it's been marin and then
everybody was like just a watered down
version of that
exactly it's maron and then it's pete
holmes and then it's
everything else oh sorry you're from
cleveland originally i don't know what
gives a [ __ ] we're done with it did you
start here or did you
[Laughter]
new york or wait a minute you're
starting to start it
it happens so when i i guess hold on i
don't know i don't want to cut you off
i just want to say you say that but
the reason you say that is because you
ha you do have
like a preternatural instinct for
hustling
for business for you know like
constructing things
not everybody does sure that's one of
the reasons why you are successful i'm a
lucky fan and one of the reasons why
people you know people
in you know that started not looking up
to you to me because you have
well i appreciate that to me it comes
easy it
yeah and it's like my dad always said it
to me he's like it's nothing personal
it's just money
that's and if you live that way you're
going to move on from [ __ ]
earlier than you earlier than you would
have that sounds like mr freed threw
some people out on the
it street like a couple of voided
contracts in my book don't forget you
[ __ ] on the way up
upstairs and wake your kids up and tell
them your dad's a loser
well i'm just saying it helps you move
on from things that aren't
working yeah well also a lot of us do
stuff where we're just like and i'm not
you know i'm guilty of that you do
something you're like i believe and i
believe and i believe and then
that's like yeah it's not hidden sure
but i also think too that there's
uh dude he came in hot yeah i love
people i love the freedom it's
it's both it's florida yeah it's florida
yeah and i don't know
the pandemic you know notwithstanding
the only experience i used to always
[ __ ] on florida too and then right
before the pandemic last year
me and my girl just for like a three
four day weekend just went down to miami
and stayed at miami beach
dude i literally feel the place [ __ ]
calling to me it's great
something about florida it's great it
also has a little bit of european to it
so it's a little bit you you know you
feel like you're in a different place
it doesn't feel like the rest of america
no no no no you see a couple of guys in
the thongs i know what you mean
beautiful
beautiful asses on those men oh man
being on being in south beach my head i
was
my neck was snapping it's and it's so i
i just think that
it's it's so nice you're also you
understand why there's no ivy league
schools there right away
yeah yeah yeah yeah i get it right
you're like i'm not [ __ ] reading i'm
going outside i'm gonna go look at
chicks yeah yeah
well i we went down for a bachelor party
and like i mean we had
like coke within like the the uber
driver got us going i was just like this
is insane i'm like
we're not even out of the terminal yet
and we already picked up i'm like this
is
this is a different kind of place still
got his number
well and then certain areas like boca
you don't have the the judy
jew ish you know it's got that new york
northeast jewish tin frozen yogurt
frozen yogurt
froyos i went to tampa tampa is a whole
nother story
talk about cocaine i some comedy clubs
you go and you mentioned did you go to
the super bowl
no i was there the week after for shows
okay and
these people i would be like i would i
started a show talking about tom brady
because i'm a huge tom brady fan i'm
from new england i'm from boston
and i'm talking about tom brady and i'm
like saying to them how
you guys are like it's like you're my
new family it's like my dad got a
divorce
and this is my new family and i'm like
yeah the you know the new family's a
little trashy
missing a couple of dates yeah there's a
yeah there's a couple of people no
cousin offers me coke and you do and i
said that cousin offered me coke
you do a coke joke most places it gets
weird
sure there they're like
doggy you awesome you know you can start
growing it up on this channel
this is a party town the one thing about
the one thing about the tampa bay
windows super bowl the
the boat parade there's nothing it's
trashy there's nothing trashier
than a boat parade and it's all it's
funny because it's great when you go
there and you see the surrounding
the the area that surrounds the kind of
the canal they went down
it's like huge you know those like huge
bars
they're like outdoor um if the best
description of these bars that like line
where they were they're outdoor
cheesecake factory yeah yeah yeah i know
exactly
it's like big seats huge drink big
you know a two-foot drink yeah tuna
tartar
tower you know like it's just with like
tortilla chips they do it real
trashy exactly it's [ __ ] raw tuna
spicy mayo with
[ __ ] tostitos you know you know the
deal
rice bottom i love it uh you know sushi
grade tuna up you know
it's great i also want to say before to
just go back when we were
we had them on the third episode and we
were so like still trying to find our
footing and
you got to launch you got to launch a
successful podcast so we're like do we
do this do this we have like our
checklist of [ __ ] to go down hey make
sure you do this and
you tried naming the fans the listeners
like the second episode
you're like shout out to all the trash
cans out there whatever
and they can't stop reading because this
is an snl sketch of two guys launching a
podcast
like you guys are literally doing
everything like fights he's like you
gotta do it i get it he's like
what dude you hit him without shout out
to the dumpsters out there shout out to
the trash cans
i remember he didn't let you get a
handful with that one
you're right i totally i i i've been so
self-aware dude that line
it's like two guys on this show all your
trash bags rate share and review yeah
it it was so funny because you do have
to do it it's cheesy you gotta do it
like to anyone listening right now if
you're watching on youtube if you're
listening
uh let me help you with your spiel
here's a new one okay and i do i've been
doing it for a while but
make it your instagram story yeah you're
good make it your instagram story
because here's what
people and i consider that like join the
patreon because look they're starting a
business like don't join the patreon
because
you you know oh what's the show like who
gonna be there no no
no join cause you enjoy this free
entertainment how much is yours a month
we do five ten five bucks a month twenty
and fifty
okay for the price of a cup of coffee
yeah yeah a cup of coffee a month you
get four hours of content okay so four
hours of ayg you know when you need or a
half a gram
and you need it when you most like it's
listen no podcasts come out on saturday
no podcast coming out on sunday except
for mine we we come out on sunday
because constant salesman right that's
what i'm saying
so i do a special bonus sunday episode
because i was like
there's some sundays i'm a podcast
listener they're just looking for
something i'm looking for some i just
need something
i need to go i got to walk somewhere i
don't want to be going to the store i
need
something just to fill the void of it
exactly so i i would say people join it
because you never know when you're going
to need it but also
make it your instagram story because
that is a that is payment we all
consider that payment when you're making
your instagram story
tag these guys because i'm sure you'll
like it you don't got nothing to [ __ ]
do nobody
the old like the best customer service
and podcasting that's right we always
get back to you so always get back to
you and
what you do and what people are like
we'll make your instagram i only got 200
followers okay
we're all looking look how you look at
people's stories
that's what everyone else is doing so
they're gonna go are you garbage you
guys got a great
artwork you guys got a great thank you
great look a name like that people are
gonna go what's that what is it what is
that and they're not gonna tell you
they're not nobody looks at your stories
and goes
they tell you like a year later you know
what man thank you you posted about are
you garbage and now i'm like a huge fan
of those guys yeah and it's like
but so everyone listening rate review
subscribe like listen
whatever like everyone let's zig while
people are zagging share the stories
baby
instagram stories make it post it tag
these guys
listen to cousin jared that's right the
big thing we get which is cool
is people like we'll tag us and go is
this garbage right so like don't take a
picture like look at my girlfriends
whatever
dude and then we come and that you do
that you repost that
dude that's a great idea that's like the
charcuterie like i when i
people my brother-in-law my
brother-in-law
like a few weeks ago was like i went
over to his house for dinner and they
had it and he's like oh i'm gonna take a
picture and tag your boy i was like
don't
he's gonna hurt your feet i was like
dude save yourself
don't [ __ ] i don't even want to be
connected to this thing don't tag me in
it how did that start by the way
i tweeted out i was going on vacation
with my girlfriend the next day i'm
right taking an uber back from the
seller
and it's like two in the morning i'm
waking up at 6 a.m
i tweet out i can tell what type of
parent you'd be by your charcuterie
board
i had no idea that this was even a thing
or was going to become a thing i kind of
caught the wave
they're just there because there was
there is a wave there's a wave
they got cool they got cool because
here's what it is
it's um it's like it's like a bait
everyone has a picture of theirs you
don't need a college education to make
one
you don't need a skill to make one all
you have to do is be able to put meat on
a [ __ ] tray yeah take a picture and
it looks fancy
and it can look fancy yeah so you don't
even have to know how to turn on an oven
and yeah people love it because no
people really [ __ ] them up though oh
dude that was crazy that's the best part
is that
because [ __ ] here's the salon here's
what are you doing
believe it's not there's so many bad
things that happen on a board my
sister-in-law does a [ __ ]
it's like one from uh steals the market
send it to the lord
be careful well i i don't want to ruin
your family i i
know fruit roll-ups in the high city
well i'll say is what people
here's what it's i actually think i've
come to this after two years of doing
this
this is my i've come to the conclusion
that charcuterie is a metaphor for life
where people are posting these and they
want the attention of people online
so they try to go when you're trying for
the attention of people online
you forget about the people that you
live with when you're looking at your
phone
you're not with the people that you're
hanging trying to hide the garbage
exactly so it's this is a big so it's a
metaphor because it's like what
the reason some of these are shitty is
because they are sitting there being
like put a pumpkin on it because it's
halloween
[ __ ] you what about the person that came
to your party that's hungry that pumpkin
took up
real real estate i saw you say that one
time in a tweet or whatever
and i that's all i think now i'm like i
can't [ __ ] eat this if you can't eat
more shrimp there's more cheese what are
we doing here
finite space that's why there's grazing
tables now which should get the [ __ ] out
of here yeah it's not do you see that no
it's trash bags or whatever like down on
a counter or like a whole table
turning a whole they're doing it online
they're like parties turning a whole
table
into like they're doing like nachos now
or they do
they have seen that animalistic you're
garbage if you're doing it what's next i
walk into my apartment the whole floor
is all charcuterie
what are we doing where are we going
with this so yeah i start drifting off
what's the best what's the best to do
how is it the best to do it well it's
all about how you were gonna make it
it's a percentage games
you have to understand the numbers meat
and cheese what about the plate i sent
you that one time
remember with the prosciutto and the and
the cheese that's all it was
see this is the problem you said it was
nice it's nice
but i don't wanna you know i'm not we
want to talk about it now
i i think i have a pretty good grasp on
what you
you're very trashy too though you have a
great grasp but this is
males men make boards
like that where they go meat cheese and
then nothing it's a caveman board and
listen i
like a little big jam and a crostini i'm
with you man
we're all with you okay i but i say
you know and women make a board that
other women will think that they're like
refined sure
so it's an aesthetic yeah it's grapes on
the vine grapes on the vine then you see
like i saw someone put
sent me one the other night the whole
thing was cucumber what the [ __ ] is this
are we feeding what are we
what are we doing here and here's here's
my rule two florida's twisted hitman
[ __ ] cucumber embarrassing me the
best
board is one okay when you show up
here's how i look at boards okay i'm
first at your party when you go to a
party what do you do you skip lunch
because they're going to be serving food
i love words i don't think he doesn't
fully might not i love
i love the good horde love hors
d'oeuvres
love a pass around app okay when you're
going to a party you say okay i'm going
to eat less because they're going to be
serving through the party
i've never thought that though you've
never thought that i'll just keep eating
yeah just keep eating you walk into a
party full
you're walking in hungry if they're
serving i would get a sandwich on the
way
i don't think that is garbage oh yeah
that is
that is a proof of garbage moment for me
it depends on the situation if it's like
uh like people i'm not really that
comfortable with i probably will get
something needed on the way there so
you're not cause i don't want to be the
oh because all five five
come on that is the fact that i walk in
on an empty stomach otherwise he's
eating shrimp in the back
that's a fat guy move that dude i walk
in on an empty
stomach he's in the linen closet with a
slice of pepperoni
i can i give you some business tip okay
that was a funny joke i want to
acknowledge
that's hilarious hey gang want to take a
quick minute talking about the good
times we're having there on the stereo
app
me and kippy every thursday night at
nine o'clock chopping it up with you
folks
yeah guys it's like a little bit of an
after party for the show we're doing it
every thursday night i have a couple of
beers i let my hair down a little bit
loosen the shoulders maybe draw a bath
get in
we take your questions live on the
stream baby
it's easy you download the app go to
www.stereo.com
kevinryan or slash h foley if you like
the big guy
we get to wet our beaks a little bit
it's a good time get involved
see you then i have an idea for you okay
go ahead and i don't want any of your
listeners taking this because you got to
do this
right after we're done you can use all
business no because i i
love a a a fresh canvas you guys are a
fresh canvasser
listen i also we have to there's nothing
better than a note
like i was someone's like you know when
people are like oh dude do people try to
tell you jokes all the time i'm like um
listen if someone has an idea for me
i'll take it
because it might open up a door to my
brain
that brings me in a direction i never
would have gotten it you got to do
because you we said jared street never
met a pitch he didn't like i'll tell you
that right now
i like pitching and i like receive it so
i
so i like pitching and catching i'll
take your ideas come to my office and
buy me lunch
i will tell you guys right now you told
me you go after two pocket
i think it was before you start david
two pockets in a row you get tired
you should start doing your alone
podcasts on the patreon you do one
but you should do one called are you fat
just it's just a one second clip of him
saying yes
see you next week folks no but fat
what's this gotta do with me and shrimp
yeah i'm
hanging on that i'm waiting for it are
you fattening the onion no because it's
a fat guy move
you don't have to be fat to be fat i'm a
fat guy i'm awesome yeah if i want are
you fat i am fat
yeah even if i lost the weight i would
still have fat guy mentality
absolutely if you lost like a hundred
pounds you'd still be the same
person you should be a fat guy 100 fat
guy i gotta lose two hundred physically
yeah right absolutely stock says 200.
200 he said to you he your doctor
your doctor legitimately said two
legitimately
bills that is like that that is like the
last bedside manner that i've ever heard
that's not even done hey yeah we start
with 20.
listen i want you to start taking an
aspen a day and lose 200 pounds
stop eating shrimp in the closet come
back when you
come back yeah let me know how it goes
what come back in 11 years
dude do it about such a ridiculous thing
say to your patient i know dude what a
guy that's my cardiologist
he said 200 you have to do a joke did
you meet him under a bridge you have a
house
in a roast jeff ross
you have to do a bit about that dude 200
pounds that is such a ridiculous
he texted me he texted me that
information and
uh i d it was i started taking the
aspirin
he texted step one you checked it off
the list halfway there doc
number one he's eating number two lose
200 pounds
he told me the 200 and i i just
responded with oh man
because i was like i don't know if
that's a joke or that could be actually
real
yeah that's i mean that's a you got to
do that on stage that's so cool
you that's so [ __ ] funny that someone
would say that to someone because it's
like you have to lose
another fat guy you have to lose me all
ultimately how much anyway i'm probably
like 220 now
if i lose 200 pounds i'll be 180. be
cleaning up
you don't have to lose 200 pounds 180
that's still yeah
i agree with free let's start with 20.
at 180 you're taking your shirt off
from the back let's get to 280. yeah
let's not get ahead of ourselves yeah
well that's the whole point i don't need
you walking the catwalk what an
idiot that doctor is to even say that to
someone like if someone said you gotta
lose stupid
i'm like okay okay move on that's the
real number yeah yeah yeah
let's doc put the stint in and let's go
clean me up clean out these arteries
i'm off this weekend can we do it now
but if you start a podcast called are
you fat where you
discuss because fat guy moves that guy
moves etiquette like because i told my
girlfriend about this podcast
and i was like uh it's called are you
garbage and they basically they're
figuring out whether you're garbage or
not
how you grew up and she was like do they
get in trouble for that she was asking
if that was offensive to people and i
was like no the way you guys do it is so
great
because it's like we're garbage your
garden so it's like come on in the
water's fine we want
a party and also you're talking about
garbage in a glowing
loving nostalgia way and it's like
that's the same thing as are you fat
would
someone go are you well you don't want
to fat no no that's not
you could have anybody of any size
that's actually the most sized
acceptance sure podcast yeah sure
i don't know not the pitch idea but this
is a let's no i love it
we had somebody in here that does a fat
guy move i can't remember what it was
everybody has one i think it was like
maybe i think it was casey smith when
she was uh
when she was a server she would have her
friends order food for and she would
scarf it down in the bathroom hilarious
that's a fat guy
what about when you go to mcdonald's
what are you doing on you getting fries
for the way home
i mean do you want you know i don't even
think he'll give you he doesn't give me
the answer i don't think he's gonna you
know
he wants the truth of the lie i want the
lie
and then i want the truth i want both i
want to hear what when someone's
you came from mcdonald's someone says
what'd you get
what do you say how would you answer
that question if i said hey listen
i thought i wouldn't tell you that i
came for mcdonald's that was bringing
you mcdonald's
home no you were just like okay how
about this
no more realistic such a lie he won't
even say he was there
all
i don't want to plug the patreon but on
the patreon we went over our last
seamless orders the one time
and it was like me and toby were
speechless at the end of it it was like
a 97 dollar breakfast
dude there's like a side of pancakes and
[ __ ]
if it's you're doing pancakes for the
table and a delivery
[Laughter]
pancakes don't get delivered can you
make sure there's four forks in there
please
four forks thank you hold on so you
let's say here's the scenario because
the more realistic version would
would be someone you get caught and i go
did you go to mcdonald's today i saw the
bag what do you say what would you say
no it's old what'd you get when you went
when you did go
i don't remember it was like forever ago
it's been in there for a while
okay what's the what's that what if you
had to give up some of the awards yeah
well i got a number six yeah what no i
don't get anything
[Laughter]
i had coffee i don't know why they gave
me a bag
and i got no the i had my niece and
nephew with me and i got them something
i just got coffee it's nice
how good you are at making up that lie
just now
like you bringing in
[Laughter]
what's up with this guy focus going to
his head oh what he's talking about
[Laughter]
[Applause]
on me i told my sister-in-law i don't
think they should be eating that stuff
but she's like
the smell the smell repulsive oh my god
you go from having mcdonald's to a hero
you're good you're amazing i'll get the
happy meal and leave the toy in the car
just to [ __ ] prove my thing
that is [ __ ] great if i go alone
it's not and i haven't done this in a
long time
we don't even believe you yeah that's
you're just yeah
dude no one here no one who is told by
the doctor they have to lose 200 pounds
hasn't been to mcdonald's recently
i don't even think that's impossible
also you just explained to us how you
lie
and then you tried better than anybody
i've ever seen wow i don't even know if
i'm getting answers out of them anymore
and listen are you even a co-host of
this show
i am a fat guy i am on i'm trying to
lose weight
all the time my whole life i i
understand the struggle
we are sympatico on this the idea that
someone goes what'd you get at
mcdonald's i am not revealing that full
order there's
no way you would there you wouldn't want
to know
i no i wouldn't no you wouldn't want to
know because we'd be worried about we'd
we'd end the show we go hey man i we
didn't mean to make fun of it but like
it's a lot you know it's a lot of
mcdonald's if it's breakfast at
mcdonald's
and i'm going home to do nothing it's
it's over
there's at least time there's at least
three sandwiches three
and two and two hash browns well
probably a coke too a large coke
not a breakfast i go with the iced
coffee there's definitely a traveler no
breakfast a traveling breakfast burrito
those things are banging something to
wear out
well the three sandwiches i could defend
if i were you they got they're small
you can get the egg you can get the two
egg mcmuffins they actually have that on
the menu yeah
double egg mcmuffin so i don't mean to
take us off track
no no no i mean no we've talked and
we've we've this is this is the show
we've got this is this we've done this
topic already no
of course and it never you know it's he
it never gets old oh we've been to the
drive through a time or two
we just literally tried to break the
fourth wall of your eating mcdonald's
and he couldn't do it and we went
right back to lies come on dude we
ordered we ordered chick-fil-a in here
one night when we were building the
studio we ordered seamless
and i don't think i was here
he ordered it on his account and they
shorted us
his sandwich you would have thought like
it changed the vibe in the building
the neighbors heard about it like it was
a scene dude
dude he was on the phone with seamless
with chick-fil-a corporate like
everybody heard from better business
bureau about 1.99 sandwiches i'd like to
talk to andrew cuomo please
everybody everybody got an earful that
is
so [ __ ] funny i already have your
first segment pull out your phone
show me your last seamless oh yeah we've
done it we've done that i mean that's a
segment on are you fat
how could that not be it's garbage i got
i got a delivery not too long ago i hope
you guys don't mind that
i'm pitching these ideas think these are
helpful things
the patreon it should be kicking the
patreon is cooking baby
patriots at a thousand i ordered
entrance i ordered a delivery not not
that long ago like in the last six
months
um where i was the only one home and it
was such a big bag that as i was closing
the door
i turned and said lunch is here to
nobody in the apartment
just so the [ __ ] [ __ ] cat's
looking at him your fake niece and
nephew that you just
throw kids let's go come so on
you're not dude ah having a good time
before we get into the patreon questions
we have to get into
i would like to hear about the special
okay
i need this audience to pull through for
me the way i pulled through for you guys
you hear that trash cans out there come
on trashcan
that's why he was pitching up top he
knew what he was doing when he walked in
yeah i knew i literally it's like the
gambler i i have a special
it's uh i taped it on new year's eve
it's called socially distance of course
this is um it's all material i usually
talk about
you know the type of [ __ ] we're just
talking about for sure i'm usually
talking about
trying to lose weight dating
relationships tv
shows and there's in the middle of my
set i do i i generally get into like
you know uh social [ __ ] a little bit
short
sometimes but it's like not i don't
think people know me for that
is this the bokeh effect or what was
this building up in your system
i i had this material that i've been
building since the beginning of the
pandemic
about the social anxieties of the
pandemic
not like your grandma dying but the idea
that people were trying to take this
moral
authority on something that was so
difficult for us all
and we all had choices tough choices we
all had
choices do i go home for the holidays do
and there's anxiety that goes with
i you know nobody wants to go home for
the holidays and
make someone that they love sick sure
and then there's these people
so it's already hard enough and let's
say you do come to the conclusion i'm
gonna go home i'll wear my mask i'll get
tested i'll do all my things
that happen offline those are all things
that happen
in between instagram pictures but then
when you post the picture of you with
your family someone goes
where's the mask oh you left and it's
like
i really don't like that attitude the
shame
and and again it's what the internet is
kind of built on and and it's like
but it kind of opened up a a a a hole
for me to make fun of it
and i'm like i like this for you guys so
it's all over
so the whole special is 35 minutes
talking about
the social anxiety stuff like that when
someone asks how
are you in 2020 how do you even answer
that question because
all of us want to eat sleep and [ __ ]
yeah and we want to make enough money
to do all three of those things
comfortably so when
in in that process in that you know in
that
you know engagement of trying to eat
sleep and [ __ ] during a year
you're also aware some people are having
the worst year
way worse than you some people are doing
way better than you that's called life
so in 2020 how do you say how are you
how do you answer that question you go
because you don't want to offend none of
us you don't be like ah it's [ __ ]
great it's killing it exactly well it's
like because we've had this podcast has
gotten successful over quarantine
exactly
we bump into other comics who are you
know struggling i think about you guys
hey what's up and i'm like
how are you doing i want to be like
[ __ ] fantastic all my dreams are
coming true i
got our own studio and hoodies coming
back
the whole [ __ ] like but then i'm like
i like how you they're like i'm [ __ ]
you know about to put a gun in there but
you're having the best comedy year of
your lives that was
just i mean life-changing life-changing
life-changing and you've moved
i love you guys seven different networks
when i just did his podcast like two
months or whatever six weeks ago he's
like
well he's like you guys have been
through nineteen different podcast
networks fifteen different studios
looking for homes i get it we found it
here at totty's
that's right baby down here at the
basement and you went out on your own
which i am
uh and i'm on my own podcast guy too so
i i appreciate that too but i'm saying
how do you answer that question and it's
like this whole thing of like oh
everyone's so offended no
not everyone's not so offended it is
human
to go i'm gonna leave out some
information that might make someone feel
uncomfortable oh
it's human and it's like to say that you
don't act that way you're just a [ __ ]
liar so it's like
again i've lived in new york and i've
lived in florida during this thing
i've seen the two sides i talk about
that on the special the difference
between new york i don't agree with new
york i don't agree with florida
where's my people our people the ones
that are rational the ones that think
about
context and nuance we're just the
quietest ones you gotta call balls and
strikes baby
exactly so we're the ones in the corner
going
we're not the ones in the comments
section being like that's [ __ ]
right baby killer whatever or the person
that's like
i'm not taking a vaccine even though
they [ __ ] sailed failed science class
like
so when when you're and again so i've
always been
in that center of the of the world and
now even calling yourself a moderate
like
people are like oh [ __ ] can't [ __ ]
find the
uh you know it's like you know what and
so the whole special
and so i got to like 20 minutes of coven
material
i call it cove material but it's really
social anxiety 2020
material and i was like if i can get to
30
35 with some interviews kind of spliced
in now i got a thing here there you go
so i went to i had shows scheduled on
new year's eve so i'm like how about we
tape it on new year's eve the last day
of the worst year of a lot of our lives
and let's talk about just 2020. and it's
fantastic and so it's called socially
distance of course and it's on youtube
and i need the audience i need you guys
i need the garbage cans out there
everything from the sanitation workers
all the way up to the new
now yeah we'll put the link in here so
you can go and check it out and we'll
tweet it we'll you know i love you guys
plug it as much as possible
i love you guys and and i so but i need
what i need for people that come in from
you know you know the um other avenues i
need the sewage people to come in
and i need the uh i need positive
comments i need likes
i need you to you know do that for me in
the same way that you're posting about
this show and how
great you guys love this show yeah
because again we're
entrepreneurs in the la in the business
of funny i
i did try to sell this entrepreneurs in
the business of [ __ ] that's right
i like that man that's right and it's
like
we and the reason i'm putting it on
youtube is like
i want a million people to watch on
youtube so that i can
sell the next one yeah there you go more
more more and it's like listen
i want and we put these things out there
that's our goal and sometimes that gets
lost in translation sometimes i think
comics were
we're too ashamed to say like no i want
to make my livelihood
on being funny and it's like it's it's
an okay thing to tell people it's
it's it's it's really uh a honest
pursuit
none of us are doing this dishonestly
you guys [ __ ]
built a studio i love it and it looks
great it looks perfect
thank you buddy i i look at this and i'm
like this is what it's all
about you know like i'm sure you went to
people like hey can
you know to to help you out to do this
like i'm sure yeah we pitched it to
[ __ ] everybody
we pitched it to gas digital that before
we started it and he said no and then we
signed there we pitched it to schultzy
he said no shout out to chelsea
love you buddy who had us on who's like
a champion of ours no it's
but nothing personal of course it's cost
money it's just money
that's right schultz didn't say no to
you because he he hates you he said no
to you because he didn't think it could
make him more money that's why
that's how people make it but it's so
funny because now he's like the biggest
champion of the show he's like taking
this under his wing it's it's like it's
super the same reason that i love you
guys like where you're like oh it's
[ __ ] funny
and they're doing it the right way and
[ __ ] doing it on their not asking for
[ __ ] you know many people are asking for
[ __ ] without providing
a lot yeah yeah you know so okay that's
my done i'm off my
nose i i i love i love a passionate
pursuit well i know i love it i think
you know i think it's
this year has been [ __ ] bananas yeah
as a stand-up comedian
everything happens and it's like you a
lot of people are forced to you know
stick and move you know what i mean and
it was like
pivot pivot i remember i was like when
this happened i was like i'm not letting
this [ __ ] break up we did we were
three episodes in with the pandemic hit
i'm like we can't
you know i was ready to check the [ __ ]
out because we were standing after we
recorded your episode we were out
front and we were all like what do you
think is going to happen with this oh it
was already that's right they were
already sanitizing the mics and [ __ ]
yeah yeah and we were like you're like i
think if you know if it gets hot it'll
just burn out like that you're like
remembering me
as a i was like that freeze got a good
head on his shoulder
he said no he said no vaccine back last
april you were talking about this thing
called q
anon and you had horns on your head or
something
you're talking about the capitol
building i don't know yeah yeah the
whole jefferson bleach
pellets knock it right out yes
so it's a it's so go watch the special
enjoy
share it share it share it thank you i'm
sure it's going to be fantastic and i
know it's going to do incredibly well it
looks
like i i hope it does so but uh other if
it doesn't
we move the [ __ ] on it's not perfect
socially socially distance of course
it's like when people at you know that
was a big thing this year where people
go of course they would just tell you a
story then they go socially
of
[Music]
i don't know if this is i don't but like
you i don't like i'll talk to my mom
she's like yeah then tina came over and
we really don't see anybody and i'm like
it sounds like
came over for dinner but she stays at
home and we weren't mad
well it's just so they don't get yelled
at of course they're assuming that you
would assume the worst of them
when i say that i hear that i hear that
a lot from especially down in the burbs
what are you doing tonight oh the birds
going out to dinner you're going out to
dinner
yeah yeah yeah but they have the windows
open what the [ __ ] is that
well there's a hibachi girl it's all
shot and fried it's all
like i feel better for saying it is that
a cool clothing
[Laughter]
i learned it from avenue q when i went
inside like shod the guy and freud the
guy
no it's a word look it's a german word
shot and freud is i'm mixing it with
uh french relax take it easy this
[ __ ] guy over here no it's getting uh
joy out of someone else's pain shot yeah
is it that exactly
yeah yeah it's fine enjoying someone
else's pain my girlfriend my wife is
german oh so
yeah yeah okay um he's waiting for him
to wedge that in
saw that drink everyone at home drank
you said it um
all right let's get into some [ __ ]
let's get into some questions it's
always a hottest wait so this episode
i i love coming on i told you this
already so this goes out and then we
now they can go to patreon is that no no
no so when when you sign up for patreon
i don't know if this is him just like
reassessing let me just plug it again
or he's really confused i don't know
either way right now he's playing
the lady on the he's walking he's gonna
walk out of here with ten percent i know
that much
he's playing the lady on the on the
wrong peel pasta maker that doesn't know
tell me ron how does it work again i
always hated her oh you nailed it
it's a [ __ ] rotisserie chicken broad
what the [ __ ] hold on you have
a mystery you ever watched the one
payment you're the same girl
i mean you ever see the one where it's
the nutribullet
there's a nutribullet one it's the
funniest one because for some reason
they made a creative decision to have a
old maid like woman with a cigarette
hanging out of her mouth you have to
look her up
and it says and you're like why did they
decide to have like
a shtick like they they do the
nutribullet nutribullet woman's
cigarette if you pose
put it in she's just in the corner being
like i don't know
and it's like she's really hamming it up
it's her big
role i don't know if that's it
cigarette woman infomercial just put
that it might not be nutribullet but
she's like
she's doing a character character yeah
yeah on
on a and it's like the character's
already done with that woman going so
how do you
do it and then for some reason just i'm
getting people with their necks
oh goddammit that ain't it
but it's so funny to me that like you
could have all you need is a woman going
so wait a minute you can
but they put it in a character but they
put it into that's like something that i
love lucy or something it was bizarre
she's like i don't know
well well what do i need a nutribullet
for my husband
never eats anything like that he's like
well well fran
yeah uh your husband's gonna it's like
why do they have like this
character there's a lot of stupid people
watching those things i like to stick
with the basics when it comes to it you
get ron paul peel telling you straight
so i didn't forget it baby i like
emerald
i like to obviously billy mays was a
[ __ ] legend rest in peace
shout out to the og a real one i don't
even mind the [ __ ]
shamwow guy you say what you want about
his uh you know sexual proclivities but
the kid moves [ __ ] merchants
or something right all right whatever i
think it was in florida do you know they
do
this like if you ever go to like trade
shows these people like
there's like a scene i used to work
trade shows i know them so you know
they were they got they made their bones
at trade shows yes
on tv comics [ __ ] can you imagine
coming up at [ __ ] trade shows i can't
imagine a young billy mays
young billy may is doing and and
conference center and [ __ ] it's like
cleveland but that's like street magic
yeah they're doing cause they're going
they're going and and now look at the
glass they're doing it for a live
audience and then they find someone like
nonstick pants nothing's on there at the
end of it yeah and they're doing like
you know they're exploding fireworks on
the pan and going look it hasn't not
even a scratch
you would like that wouldn't you miss
but just think how bizarre that must be
to see that in person like on a carpeted
floor
yes of like a like a ball they set up
chairs and stuff and like we would get
there be like anybody have you seen the
copper pan guy he's [ __ ] killing it
over an aisle h
and it's amazing that someone could be
like i gotta pick you up like someone
would find you like they would at a
comedy club
those guys are kids
who's the new kid the guy that does the
flex seal yeah the flex steel guy yeah
a new kid he's like 45. he's like a
[ __ ] short fat old guy
but how has there been he's a new kid on
the scene how has there not been a movie
about that world oh wow
they were supposed to make a movie this
is a little bit different but do you
remember the winnebago guy the guy that
would freak out
so i i know that that movie happened
right no they were i don't know if they
ever did it i thought they were supposed
there was a documentary
yeah there's a documentary but i agree
with you 100 percent like that world
seems like it's made for a judd apatow
movie
super interesting like a deep cut like a
dodge ball like it kind of feels like
yeah okay yeah those guys are all good
[ __ ] whack-a-doos they all got to be
[ __ ] hard charged crazy that's why
that guy's biting off [ __ ]
yeah dude this is this
should be called the pitch cast
people come in pitch it i love it i hate
it
uh what free does have the shamware
factor
constant salesman sing dance and dust
thank you no mike toby
brought to you by no mike tobey he
screwed him i'm sorry is the old lady
smoking
he's really he comes in here pitching
bits
all the time my husband frank
loves a fish could be blend yet we just
got a
couple blend jets it's not blend yet
blend that's nice i don't even know what
that is
it's the it's a [ __ ] the wand no
no what am i an [ __ ] with the thing
that cooks the meat the boiling stuff
get out of here with that the souvenir
whatever it's called
i haven't
[Laughter]
i don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about the blend jet is like a
little it's like a little mini
immersion blender no it's a little mini
blender that
every the cup is the blender it's got to
be the same as the nutribullet i mean
it's similar but it doesn't work vitamix
family by the way
got a little bit of cage we're doing all
right patreon.com
it spins so fast it gets hot but how
does it work i don't know
all right let's get into some [ __ ]
questions 47 minutes in
you know we got a hot one 47 minutes
to a question maybe you know i can bring
it i love it uh guys uh so when you sign
up for the patreon we will answer one of
your questions
that brings us to where we are right now
oh so these are
questions submitted on patreon we answer
on the regular app yeah so when we have
guests come back we answer patreon
questions
it's a family guys family thank you
um all right this is from joseph tully
uh
kelly would you have to or have you ever
routinely have to walk to a different
sink to wash your hands after dropping a
deuce since the soap dispenser was
consistently out of soap
i gotta say that's currently the issue
today in my apartment
we're out of soap in the bathroom so i
drop a deuce and then walk to the
kitchen to wash my hands
what do you do you do what do you do
pump it at the sink in the bathroom look
at it
we do foley's looking at you like he
ever washes yeah i know it's true
he is going this is an acting
performance i've never seen before
he's like yeah this is as good as the
mcdonald's him
asking to read ask the question i don't
know what you mean
you're washing your hands fully i'll be
honest with you hand sanitizer has
ruined me
oh that's not the same you got poop on
your hand [ __ ] sansan he ain't taking
it off
i don't do i just makes it smell a
little different and i used to i use the
bleach ones too i just use the wipes
he uses like clorox wipes for like
surfaces
no just and i will use this on his
wife's right there i'll use those wipes
to wipe my hands why wouldn't i
because you wouldn't because i don't
know it's not for human [ __ ]
consumption what's that going to do dude
yeah
that ain't good i mean it might be okay
yeah clean and fresh down there eat off
that bottle
wait you use hold up no not to white to
wipe your ass no no no the clorox
not the chlorine have you ever done that
no not the clorox
that'll [ __ ] wake you up that'll put
a little pepper oh my god
that's the infomercial i want to see the
scrubbing bubbles baby i've been using
these things all wrong
[Laughter]
plus takes the stains away doing one no
not the bleach ones
but the the the regular like you know
the lysol ones
i will i ha i have yeah there's bleach
that i have there's
nothing lysol lysol is on a bleach cup
chemicals
i don't think you want to use the light
salt ones on your [ __ ]
the way you said that so casually is
insane because that's an insane
statement yeah you don't want to use the
lysol wipes on you you got to see the
shine and no streaks
plus that lemon scent really goes a long
way i have never walked to another
really what if there's no soap at that
bathroom
i'd be out i'm i'm you're just done
there you go i tried i made my brush
after you took it didn't work after a
poop i i if you're home if i
is there no mess in my hands are we
assuming that my hands are a mess with
poop
no not a mess but just a regular regular
poop you're not watching
i'd just be like [ __ ] it i i i'm more
lazy than i am gorgeous
i didn't wash my hands for a long time
would you go right okay so after that
could you go right to the kitchen and
start handling like deli meat
i mean i'm not preferring to but i could
pop my head you know if he goes and
watches tv for an hour then goes yeah
that's a different story on the couch
that's the statue of limitations right
now i'm wiping on my pants a little bit
sure let me ask you this sure is it a
bar of soap that you're missing or is it
a pump
no so we take the what is it the miss
miss meyers or mrs meyers the meyer soap
and we have a dispenser that matches so
we pour the bottle
into the dispenser we've currently ran
out of our surplus
very very very new money yeah the buyers
everything you just described is very
new money
the home goods dispenser i'm going to
vote
yeah going to myers myers the new age
well it's like whatever it's my it's my
my
there's a lot of dr brahmer's in my
house right now a little too much
she got a thing for him she does yeah
that and we stumbled across beekman's
1802
goat milk soap now we get that for every
[ __ ] present
every time from my mom we have 45 people
mom soap
no my mom gets us soap oh arcadia i'm
telling you check it out it's fantastic
plugged city here yeah right what are
you wetting your beak on the back end
with this beakman's
what is this my beak's all wet i
apologize um
i'll walk to the sink but i'll usually
use dish washing soap yeah
you got to get some soap it's the effort
freeze is just [ __ ]
crazy no man's land out here listen this
guy's not something there's some belief
that the germs
are what keep you healthy i don't hate
it bro you've been in florida
[Laughter]
you need to go for a walk in central
park and reassociate yourself
yeah yeah walking here i was like this
is a dicey neighborhood
you gotta get the z balls
that's my you need something you need
somebody oh my god thank you yeah
somebody get this kid a bobcat are you
jesus christ that's my u.n
or no what's that that's my uh yeah it's
your consulate or whatever
you're you're you're in a different
you're you're your mullet starts
shrinking as you're eating it oh
my god oh phew oh god
um all right this is from max what's the
farthest you've ever driven or traveled
for a specific food item or beverage
that's have you ever made like a drip
drink at some point
a restaurant a fast food because i know
in college for us uh there was always
sonic commercials but no sonic anywhere
[ __ ] drove me nuts right yeah but
then sonic opened up in our neighborhood
[ __ ] stunk but we made that a script
we were like
yo friday sonic we're going but we did
white castle because harold and kumar
came out when we were in college
and there wasn't any in philly but there
was that one they went to in jersey
supposedly sure so it was like an hour
and a half or whatever then you went to
the [ __ ] movie set white castle
no i mean there's only there's like two
in we didn't go because of the movie
that's the only white castle closest to
us in philadelphia in college
in college a couple of ladies man huh
wild nights out it's like it was like
sunday it was like saturday night we
talked about it and then we'll see yeah
and yeah
i wanna know what this is like let's get
a bunch of weed well you would you had
never had white castles no never
and what do you think i wasn't a fan
jared fan
i it's got to be hot it's it's if it
gets cold the minute that
again drops get the [ __ ] out of florida
it's gotta be hot what are we doing hot
hot
white castle oh like if you ever have if
you haven't like can you boil this after
it's got a short shelf life
short shot yeah it's gotta be it's yeah
it's not this
like it's not pizza no it's got the
shelf life of a goldfish
yeah that's good totally true i've done
a drive i um
my family used to go do drives to this
place
harry's uh for fried clams it's good
it's got to be fantastic a place called
harry's i knew it was going to be some
sort of
food because it's not a seafood name
that's how you know it's good
because it's stuck around for so long
clams with the bellies if you get
clam strips your [ __ ] garbage clam
strips
are that is a you know grow up
what's with the bellies because i've
only known clam strips but maybe
clam strips are like will come frozen in
like you know
in the frozen aisle so what's with the
bellies actually the
bellies of the clam is where actual the
taste really
sure in the actual clam party ex and the
clam parts right you want the bellies
with the clams
if you look it up close the strips the
strips you can tell it's like what you
would hold the belly
right yeah they rip it out when they sit
when they do them
well they rip it out when they want to
when someone's a child and gets
you're a [ __ ] baby it's just there's
no taste to it there's no
there's no integrity the the fried clams
with the bellies and
onion rings well done at harry's we
would go as a family
i believe that was your old man that was
your old man's night huh yeah we're
going to probably
loved it tartar sauce of course yeah
a tartar sauce extra more and more and
more next year
that was armada because i remember from
your first episode
your dad we asked you a lot of questions
you're like no but my dad did that like
yeah your dad's a little
more rough around the edges
you can't if you get them without the
belly you know what i mean they're like
oh yeah yeah yeah
with the belly has your drink of choice
change since you've been down there
are you doing like mojitos or something
now it's funny you've mentioned how many
diet cokes because it's tough
no diet coke when you go somewhere it
changes the vibe you ch
i want this now getting the cuban coffee
down here
i you can't boca you get the jewish
coffee it's you know it's not starbucks
it's like yeah i'll have a large skinny
that's how i order now but i i my mom
drinks
and my grandmother use no my grandmother
used to drink vodka on the rocks with a
lime that was her
my grandmother's hardcore you've seen
some [ __ ] my mom
drinks orange vodka on the rocks with a
slice of orange
i have moved that is what i'm living in
really i feel that's pretty trashy i
feel the flavored vodki's
vodkas are trash if you're going slowly
you have to go stolen absolute
absolute's a little too flavorful for me
stole is really on the nose stole he got
stolen flavored that's that's totally
exciting that's where i'm going
on the rocks with a lime i don't know
that's my drink and because also i was
trying to be healthier
yeah yeah yeah lose weight what was the
frequency of a cocktail down there for
the
for the thing were you were you were you
making one at like three when you got
nothing to do
you were in their lifestyle right
because that's what happened you were on
vacation the problem is they're in this
community
and because of it they wouldn't i wasn't
allowed to like go to like
there's like a you know there's like a
night bar place where people can hang
out like they've got everything
so yeah with like hors d'oeuvres and
[ __ ] you would
love it they got like we got they're
doing wings like a country club without
the walking
country club yeah that they're living in
a country club so they
so they but we would have like five
o'clock
wednesday gavin yeah
we want to drink you know let's have a
take the edge off fried's getting the
early
quarantine the quarantine really
shortened the week for me i'd like it's
wednesday i can have a drink it's been a
long
week you only did monday and tuesday
absolutely
i know man that's [ __ ] awesome um all
right let's let's burn through a couple
more of these because we got to get out
of here this is from eric have you ever
worn a t-shirt in a hot tub
i don't know how that's garbage but i
have for sure you have
back there was like i was always a fat
kid there was a time when like
i was self-conscious about it maybe for
like a summer or two or whatever where i
i'm sure i can't remember but i'm sure
sure i got titties
yeah and it's have you done that let me
tell you something he's got no body
shame this guy
he's good for you he's the best i i
there was a half a second
at the at the town line pool community
pool
where i put the shirt on and i was like
you know what hot tub no not a hot tub
in a pool in the pool downline
[ __ ] townhome association they didn't
have a hot tub freed
that's how much money this guy's got
[Laughter]
he didn't know what a hot dog was until
he got older might as well been on star
wars
before or after you played polo what
happened was to understand
um we had a creek but we used to get
crayfish does that count
i don't think they were real crayfish
not in a creek in pennsylvania
just saying the word creek made me want
to
barf i i really felt sick at the work
well that was a trashier version which
is quick
brick is way trashier than creek jumped
but if you've got a creek if you're
going yeah down the creek
not good yeah it was really just a storm
drain
we went in there i feel like a real
heavy rain one time and i look back on
it i'm like the house
was so we would have gotten that
happening didn't they get to get sucked
down during the rain or something i
don't know i was too young for that
movie no he was in the sewer
whatever anywho any who ah
you were were you ever a shirt in the
pool guy or are you a smaller kid i like
that
to come back with that kid wait always
but um
i also like you know i'm from foley
school of things where it's like
i put my foot down i had it on for a
half a second in the pool i was like i'm
not [ __ ] doing this the problem when
you're overweight and you wear the shirt
in the pool now
you're admitting to it it's tough to
come back
yeah you can't come back from that and
it makes you look worse the titty gets
it looks worse
the fact that you got you were in a hot
tub that is like disgusting to me yeah
it's weird
a shirt and a hot tub like that no i'm
not
you know when you're like you're so hot
yeah you know when your body starts not
really keeping that much heat in
you're in a [ __ ] hot tub it's going
to be hot water exactly but you know
that feeling after you get out of a hot
tub where you're like your body's like
not really the right temperature for the
air
and you kind of feel a little sick from
it that shirt would make me feel more
sick
yeah i'm not saying i'm not saying i was
making right decisions here you know
what i mean i was
i was 12 in a bad place in a hot tub
turn my uncle turtleneck and sweatpants
cooling off um i pissed uh this is from
dave mo uh have you ever tried to pick
up someone at a wake or a funeral i mean
some of you guys are [ __ ] savages
i don't know no i can't i don't know so
what kind of wakes and fuels are you
going to where there's a lot
here's here's where you can pick up a
chick
and and it happens a lot actually and
it's not
thought of the same way but jewish
people have shiva calls
and the shiva calls it's more of a hang
right it's more of a hang you're sitting
oh and sitting shiva it's like i think
five days
and basically someone usually it's one
of the family members
has food and every night every and
everyone comes over
and i actually i'm like i'm a big i'm a
big like i'm a shiva call lover like i
think it's like a great way to deal with
death
what a great invention by the jewish
people by the fourth
fifth day it's like all right let's get
over it enough all right have a couple
of [ __ ] drinks well that's what that
is
but that happens a lot you know people
that are like dinner every night free
dinner
you're like are you here for me or your
[ __ ] dinner you know so
um but it happens a lot of shiva calls
where you meet a lot of like
my you know a lot of people that are
like jewish people are always looking to
fix you up with jews
sure it can that it can happen there i
probably i
there's no question i've been in a shiva
call and had like an aunt or someone
being like a friend or whatever and go
yeah you gotta meet
the original j date basically are you
hooking up with them
they're at the shiva no you're light
you're covering ground oh i'm sorry i'm
the dirt bag all of a sudden
you make a move on her in the bathroom
around here you make a move on her when
on the bed where all the coats are
thrown
well they're not there you're usually
getting
oh you got to meet you gotta meet carol
you gotta
oh take my number take your number i'm
gonna send her your instagram you know
whatever nice
um all right let's do uh two more this
is from uhuru
i love it shout out uh have you ever
posted a picture of your car
on social media just your car no
no do you have a car now no no no i
wouldn't want anybody to know
no one's coming after your jeep liberty
i don't know
[Laughter]
it's not a liberty and it's not gray
yeah that's one of those things that
like the
sitting against your camaro i never
understood like
you wonder that like that guy's never
like
heard of people making fun of people
yeah there's no self-awareness yeah
i also i was i sold not too long ago
this guy get dre we're driving
i think i talked about it they got out
of their car to take a picture next to a
lamborghini and then got back in their
car and i was yeah that's the ultimate
that's insane and they were like 40
something
so they went to someone else's car the
car was parked they were driving down
the street saw it
got out took pictures in front of it
then got back in their car and left it's
such a
defeatist move yeah they got back in
like a chorus or something
yeah but think of how little hope you
have i know yeah you're like i'll never
have this opportunity
to take a picture in front of one again
well just think how delusional you have
to be to post that or something and
to think that people are going to think
you're cool for doing it or
who the [ __ ] gonna think that randy
all of a sudden
for a [ __ ] lamborghini in his jean
jacket that actually happened once there
was there was someone
there was someone that posed must have
sold his beanie babies
people do [ __ ] like that on social media
though where though they just let people
believe
oh sure there was a girl that i used to
know and she was trying to make it in
something but she posted a picture and
it was
her name it was a new york city brick
wall but then
she had photoshopped the brick wall to
look like
uh it was a billboard of her name for
her business
and people were commenting you made it
new york city billboard that's crazy and
i'm
sitting there being like what like
like insane no like if that were me and
i posted a picture like that like oh
look at the j
trampaka this is on a billboard new york
and people were saying like whoa
billboard new york i would write back oh
it's a joke guys
letting you know like not a [ __ ]
[ __ ] she was responding everyone
thank you
it's been such a long ride you're like
you [ __ ] delusional
[ __ ] that happened to people stink
that happened a little bow wow
yeah he tweeted a picture of him on a
private jet being like yo wheels up
headed to chicago or whatever and then
somebody follows him
on instagram and was sitting next to him
on the plane and then took a picture of
him on like united
52. i was like nah dude you're not even
in first class it's funny
it's so funny um ah it's trash
all right let's do one more here
excellent what a fun time here hot water
hot thanks for coming in uh this is from
nick's day how often do you eat over the
sink
big man i'm looking at you uh this
my sink now i'm not that he moved it to
the couch i'm not
the cat you just agree with that before
the joker
no i thought you meant well the couch
has become my new sink i eat i eat on
the couch a lot
but at my mom's for some reason i don't
know it just feels good to eat a
sandwich over the sink your mom has an
open more open floor plan as well i love
i love eating in the kitchen
like just standing there you know what i
mean a little cheese little pepperoni
not too shabby
how about you you a sink eater no no i
might see this is the the whole point of
the
kitchen island we got a huge island in
my mom's house
the kitchen island enters the picture
the sink eating it's a razzle wedding
there's no need no you don't need it
anymore island's great
yeah my cousin has an island and we do
christmas day there
and that's always the hot spot that's
the spot everybody's putting out the
that's where the honduras stuff's going
your cool ants there having a cocktail i
love it everybody's hashing it up mixing
it up
it's the scene it's the waterhole of the
it's the cool kid's table yeah that's
right the cool kids table now yeah you
can hold some cord around a [ __ ] nice
island
come on tell them some stories making
fun of uncle uncle randy or whatever
clean up after dinner then all of a
sudden [ __ ] it's all clean and the
desserts go out cause
they're going around granite god damn it
granite
i love it nice all right we got to wrap
this up
yes what a fantastic episode maybe
the special socially distanced of course
jared freed thank you all about the
social anxieties of 2020
filmed on new year's eve in indianapolis
it's out on his youtube page
right [ __ ] now make sure you check it
out we love it buddy what else you got
for me that's it that's it just go you
know
and if you on instagram it's i'm going
to be posting that link everywhere thank
you guys for posting of course
yeah yeah we'll post it everywhere jared
freed on instagram that's where it's all
going to be
and tuesday it came out tuesday this
will come out after that but it's out
it's there
comment go subscribe drop a like drop a
comment even if you don't watch it just
[ __ ] get it
get to get the algorithm working watch
it but i'm saying it and it's 35 minutes
it's not you know i'm not looking at it
easy-peasy
preach to you and it's all jokes we love
it thank you for coming in buddy
thank you for being such a paladin with
us we love having you over uh kippy what
do you got for him
uh at cameron comedy on all social media
and then please make sure you review
subscribe on itunes
follow all you garbage and all social
media garbage
uh patreon.com garbage you sign up for
all that bonus content we were talking
about it's a good [ __ ] time baby
subscribe on youtube
thank you so much we love you at age
fully on ice on twitter and foldygrams
on instagram t-bone
thank you buddy thanks brother we'll see
you guys next week peace
hold on there kids wait one second want
to talk to you real quick before you run
off
to go play tag or [ __ ] meet up at
your buddy's house or whatever it gives
you kids do after school
want to talk to you about the fun time
we're having air on a stereo app
doesn't matter whether you have an
iphone or an android no matter
sign up for free and it's a fun time
yeah guys a good app there's a lot of
good shows on there we're on there
weekly baby answering your garbage
questions
if you got something you've been
thinking about this is an easy way to
get involved with the show
oh yeah you record your question live we
answer it live
yep we're mixing it up with you guys
live live
old hang baby the after party we'll see
you there use the link in the
description to sign
up let the boys wet their beaks a little
bit oh yeah
see you there thursday nights nine
o'clock peace